now why did i just put my phone on the
roof
this video is all about conducting an
experiment and i need to take
every precaution i'm just very very very
convinced
that tick-tock is spying on me
you're probably uh picking up on a lot
of chaotic energy right now and that's
fair and it's because
i'm pretty sure tick-tock has been
spying on me i just have yet to catch
tick-tock in the act of spying on me for
the next week
i'm going to be staging fake
conversations around my phone
in order to bait tick-tock into serving
me a
targeted video on my for you page should
i be
having these fake conversations while
i'm using tiktok should i be having
these conversations well tiktok is open
in the background but i'm using a
different app should i be having these
conversations while my phone is just
sitting there so in the name of science
and to just
check all the boxes we're gonna do all
three while i am using tiktok the app
itself
i will be planting the code word french
toast
while i'm using my phone but tiktok is
running in the background i will be
planting the code word
umbrella and finally while keeping my
phone in a tight radius of me
i will be planting the code word walrus
here we go i want to see either french
toast
umbrella walrus or god help us
all three i have just been absolutely
craving french toast lately i don't know
what they put in it if it was
uh like vanilla extract which do you
think is better french toast or pancakes
definitely french toast i agree all
right so you know just scrolling around
twitter youtube i don't remember if it's
gonna rain tomorrow do you know if i'm
gonna need an
umbrella like what makes a good umbrella
i feel like all the umbrellas i get are
so
crappy have you ever seen a walrus in
person
definitely not you've never seen a
walrus walruses are the ones with the
huge
tusks in the little uh goatee right
alrighty it is the end of day one
we have to check tick tock for french
toast
umbrella and walrus here we go
there was something that resembled
something similar to french toast
and i almost had a heart attack
[Music]
i think we've given the for you page a
fair shot tonight
on today too
before we get into day two i wanted to
make sure i mentioned that anytime you
see this shot anytime we're having this
conversation
my phone is on lockdown just last week i
was having a conversation about a very
specific street food and then days later
i got a tick tock on my for you page of
that exact
street food i'm going to share one more
example that is a little embarrassing in
conversation with my wife around our
apartment i will refer to my stomach
as my pooch i'm sharing this because a
few days ago on my for you page i get a
tick tock how to get rid of your belly
pooch that's why i'm doing this
experiment i know what's happening i
just need to
catch tick tock in the act of listening
to me
i think the key to a good french toast
is a good bread
i could really go for some french toast
oh man i really need an umbrella all
i've got is my coat
that's not gonna cut it i need an
umbrella it's raining
i would love to just curl up on the
couch with a nice big
walrus i bet a walrus
would love this weather they're in the
ocean they're in the water all the time
a little rain never hurt a walrus we're
at the very end of day two gonna look at
tic tac
one more time before bed
day two of the experiment no luck
even though this experiment is for a
week i really thought we were gonna be
somewhere by now overall it's way more
draining than i thought it would be of
what can i say around my phone what can
i say on camera did i say the wrong
thing into the phone am i saying the
right thing into the camera i just need
to see something
day number three of doing nothing out of
the ordinary just talking about my
favorite things out loud like i always
do right
i really wish i just had someone tell me
how to make french toast
if anyone's listening can you show me
how to make french toast anyone who's
listening who thinks i'm running out of
ways to talk about umbrellas
no way i could talk about umbrellas all
day i just wish i could look at umbrella
the only thing that would make this day
better is if i just saw some umbrella
reply in the comments with your number
one
favorite sea mammal i don't know if a
walrus is a sea mammal
if i'm wrong i want someone to correct
me by showing me a walrus may i
have a walrus please may i please have a
walrus
we're gonna check tick-tock see what's
going on
i feel like i'm going insane because i
just got a tick tock about how to
replace a light on the ceiling
okay and i was at the hardware store
yesterday
getting the tools to replace the light
on the ceiling help me
where do i start in the midst of
shooting this video
my wife gets a tick tock about finding a
dress for a wedding i
swear on my life days before we were in
a vintage store
talking about dresses for weddings and
at the rate things are going
i think we have to switch up the words
we gotta keep tick tock on its toes
while using tick-tock
candle while using other apps eggplant
while my phone is nearby scorpion new
words
every time i look around this bathroom i
feel like i need a candle i'm also not
sure on scent
like this it's a eucalyptus vibe in here
i don't want to be cocky but i've got a
nose for
candles i've never really picked a bad
candle
if there's one vegetable i would love to
master
it's the eggplant when i go to the store
i don't even know if
i know how to tell a good eggplant from
a bad eggplant
normally i am not that bothered by
insects but for some reason
scorpions just don't sit well with me
it's the poison it's the
the pincers i wonder if i should start
manifesting a scorpion encounter just to
see what i'm made of
time to check tick-tock
come on
i'm not even frustrated at this point
i'm just
mad but that's okay we gotta keep it
moving we need three new words while i'm
using tiktok
owl while i'm using other apps baseball
while the phone is nearby
soup let's just get back to it
[Music]
that's the sound of one of my favorite
birds
the owl it's a shame that owls are
nocturnal because i would love to see
owls more during the day if possible
keep your eyes peeled for the owls and
the trees maybe they're here maybe
they're not let's be honest it's a
beautiful day
for baseball um anybody think i should
just stop some random person on the
sidewalk and ask if they want to play
baseball with me
ask if they want to have a catch is
baseball one of those sports i'm just
supposed to like
some soup on a warm day i guess there's
cold soup is that what gazpacho is
all this walking worked up quite an
appetite a big bowl of soup should help
take care of that is gazpacho with soup
even though it's cold
hunting for soup hunting for soup
here we go
[Music]
[Music]
what does this mean i was while i was
using the tick tock app there were so
many times where
it happened but i wasn't able to
document it and then i finally just
slammed it into tick tock i don't know i
don't know
as satisfying as it was to see that owl
can i definitively say that tiktok was
listening to me and
showed me an owl maybe something i
thought about while doing this
experiment some of the targeted tick
tocks i got were pretty big so maybe
it's tick tock just
funneling viral videos through their
algorithm but then other tick tocks that
were about things i was
speaking about that were on the small
side it really makes my brain hurt in
terms of how that lands up
in my eyes will i be going back on tik
tok for hours on end day after day
i'm gonna try not to thank you for
showing me what i wanted to see but also
not thank you for listening to me when i
don't want you to be listening to me
you